the reverend dr martin luther king jr's
daughter
bernice is calling on congress to
restore voting rights protections
now it's a cause that was championed by
congressman john lewis
she made the comments at the lewis
funeral yesterday
as we honor the life of congressman john
lewis
who shed blood on that edmund pres
pettis bridge
that we might have the right to vote
grant that we
never again take that right for granted
and that we exercise it no matter what
and that we never again tamper with that
right
overtaking this hour our congress
that they might restore voting rights
protections
in our nation lewis as you know
died earlier this month after fighting
pancreatic cancer
wesley lowery is a correspondent for 60
and six
and he wrote a lengthy obituary for
lewis in gq magazine
60 in six features 60-minute style
storytelling
and around six-minute episodes it airs
on the streaming at quibby
and is produced by cbs news which is a
part of viacom cbs an investor in quibby
wesley good morning it seems every time
you come on i'm raving about a piece you
wrote
and here i go again about that gq piece
it was so beautifully written i thought
you captured him so brilliantly
because of all the people you talked to
but in part you wrote this
you said john lewis quote is a breathing
civil rights monument
and that he was a bridge for civil
rights from the civil rights movement to
the contemporary world
an enduring reminder of how the nation's
past shapes its presence
shapes its present i read that and i
went go you go let wes
lowry you go so after all the people
that you've talked to because i really
think you captured the man and his
mission
after all the people you talked to and
you talked to many people in his life
how do you sum him up
certainly you know i think that you know
john lewis
in many ways was someone with a real
integrity
um of spirit and of mission a real true
believer
in uh nonviolent philosophy um but also
in agitating to try to change the
country and make it better
and you know i think that you know
that sentence that you highlighted this
idea that he's kind of in many ways or
he was
a living monument but but also right
there can be a temptation with that to
you know almost turn him into a santa
claus figure right well that's john
lewis he did that thing
so many years ago but the fact that he
was still with us was a reminder that
these struggles weren't that long ago
right that that we're not that far
removed from the civil rights era that's
not to suggest that there haven't been
major changes and that
we we aren't getting better on these
things but it was this reminder that you
know i think sometimes with history we
like to pretend that things were
longer ago than they were because we
would never do such a thing or how could
we
and john lewis was a reminder that this
fight kind of was still going on because
here's this boy who who was beaten on
the edmond penis bridge for the right to
vote and if he's still alive
if he's still here with us then that
couldn't have been so long ago
yeah hey wes did you ever get a chance
to meet him by chance during your
travels did you ever spend any time with
him
certainly yeah i spent some time with
john lewis when i actually first got to
the washington post years ago i was
covering congress primarily and so
i i would run into congressman lewis uh
just in the hallways
you know and have conversations and talk
and you know we weren't uh particularly
close there were many reporters and
colleagues of mine who were closer to
him than i was but
but i knew john lewis and had interacted
with him and and he was just he was
someone who always
took the time to talk to have
conversations there was a humility that
kind of
radiated off of him in a way that isn't
always true of our elected officials
right it isn't always true
frankly even of other great people and
that was something that was so
particular
yeah listen we all treasure those times
now they
they take on to me a very different
meaning and his final words to us in his
new york times op-ed he says
the most powerful non-violent change
agent we have
what's at stake he's he said the voting
he was talking about voting it's the
most powerful non-violent change agent
we have
what's at stake do you think in the
fight against voter suppression it's a
very serious thing coming up with the
election
in november it certainly
is you know and we saw both what
representative lewis wrote in his final
words and then what
uh bernice king and then later barack
obama said in their eulogies yesterday
right that this fight over access to the
ballot box is real
it's something that's still going on for
a lot of people it's not a settled
question and so there's a lot at stake
there right
we still have major questions to answer
right about voting rights in places like
dc or puerto rico or
should we do automatic registration or a
federal holiday
and so you know this is not a fight
that's over and i think that that's
something that
uh representative lewis talked about
often right and i think one of the
things he said
and he wrote this in this in the piece
was at times there can be this
sense that you know people feel as if
they voted and it hasn't paid off for
them or
they feel disenchanted but he noted that
you know in a democracy
the vote is the most powerful tool um
and he was urging
a lot of the young activists and
protesters he supported them and
supported the work they were doing in
the streets but he was urging them to
show up in november as well
yeah and he's certainly passed on the
baton to the next generation of
activists
what do you think that they can learn
from him briefly
certainly you know look i think that
it's a resilience
you know john lewis was beaten to within
inches of his life
not just once not just on the bridge
many other times and
and and so i know i talk to a lot of
activists and they get discouraged at
times but i think that you know
uh john lewis is a representation of
uh you know getting knocked down and
getting back up uh because if
if the thing you're fighting for is
worth it you got to keep getting back up
yeah i marvel that he was never that he
was never bitter he was always very very
brave thank you wes
laurie for your time can't wait to read
your next piece thanks a lot
you can watch 60 and six on the mobile
streaming app quibby
congressman john lewis's legacy of good
trouble inspires us all
so we at cbs are very excited to honor
him with a very unique tribute and prime
time special featuring
some of the biggest names in
entertainment so how did this idea
came about oprah and tyler as in winfrey
and perry went to viacom cbs and pitched
the idea viacom cbs said yes
then they invited brad pitt to be one of
the hosts he said yes
then they invited me to be one of the
hosts you know i said yes
our focus is on the deep sense of
empathy and justice
that guided louis which all of us strive
to echo these days it features very
special performances by artists like
common and john legend here's a first
look
that's why we walk through america with
our hands up
when they go down we woman and man up
they say stay down
and we stand up shots we on the ground
the camera panned up
king pointed to the mountaintop and we
ran up